Denver baby back from Denver and they
call it some people call it men ver men
ver you know like they got more men over
there but I saw a good uh I definitely
saw a decent gaggle of Mountain kitten
you know kind of just scheming about I
saw a lot of beautiful wahh seem like a
lot of beautiful women over there I mean
a lot of where at a distance could have
been um you know transvestites or wigged
men and there are a lot of wigged men
out there a lot of wonderful people
visited the shows a lot of Hill people a
lot of Mountain errs you know you can um
you know you see a lot of people come
down they got different furs on them
different in Denver you don't know so
sometime you'll see that you'll you'll
be petting something and you'll think
it's a Great Dane and then it'll kind of
lift up and it's got a Starbucks then
it's some fella maybe some fella named
Randy or something he just had on the
fur you know you see a lot of uh
crouching Randy's or crouching Tigers
hitting Randy's you know you think
something it's like oh there's a sheep
and it's oh that's Vanessa you know she
was just bending down picking up
something she dropped her phone because
people we're exotic furs a lot of sheep
a lot of um seal you'll see somebody
wearing seal fur seal skin so you
definitely have that wildness out there
a lot of neat people came out fat Trish
came out shout out fat Trish shout out I
met this guy who said that I bummed a
cigarette off of him in 2001 so that was
pretty cool
my boy Eric came out little Doyle gay
Henry this dude who was he just kept
increasing the gay amount as the night
went on you got those buddies you know
you know at 10 o'clock they are
there you know there Brad Pitt at 10
p.m. and by 2 a.m. they [ __ ] ballbag
Lance a lot you know they just see like
whoa whoa we really shift in here
Ronny big Ronnie came out with that but
with those buck teeth respect and um I
think that was about everybody a lot of
people with Mountain asthma a lot of mas
the mountain asthmatics and the air when
you get into Colorado the air has a
little bit of the air just feels thicker
like it's got shoulders on it like you
just that air it hit the sides your
lungs that what you doing boy what you
doing you better be doing something oh
wait it's refreshing there's something
refreshing there and that's a gift a lot
of places do not have that but they have
it there and and what a beautiful group
of people to come on out and enjoy life
with when as Denver where the air has
got that that air is like it's wearing a
shoulder pads hit you you know that airs
got something in it it's got something
going on every breath you take you can
feel that it that that that that inhale
that that it's got a mother and a father
out there you know every you know when
you inhale the air out there in Colorado
you could feel the wind in the distance
looking for its baby that you just took
off the planet
it's Colorado man this is Colorado and
that's a native word I'm sure what does
it mean let me look it up right now
actually
shout outs all like three different
dudes came out that had a Trey Anastasio
tattoos on their back too
and uh Colorado is of Spanish origin
meaning color red the name was applied
to the Colorado River because of the red
sandstone style of the region and there
you go
so never too late to get some facts back
in Los Angeles back from the mountains
back from the I mean it's just really
just uh it's almost like you say you
opened up a refrigerator and all that's
inside of it is a bunch of nature and
there's a little mountain over there and
a mountain all the mountain is is a
mountain is just a bunch of land got
together and just said now what [ __ ]
you feel me you know saying a mountain
is just like a gang of land
it's basically ms-13 of dirt that's all
a mountain is brah you know a prairie
looks over at a mountain or you know
like a valley looks at a mountain it's
like damn these dudes are bullies that's
all it is but shout out everybody bro
thank you guys for checking out this
clip and if you want to see another clip
then you can look at this clip or this
clip either one of these so did you pick
one or he's still just watching me do
this cuz it's alarming